bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur france 3
normandie dans cette voie est libre
spéciale consacrée aux élections
régionales des 6 et 13 décembre prochain
nous sommes donc un tout petit peu moins
d'un mois du premier tour de ces
élections régionales vous accueillons
aujourd'hui ici à la médiathèque
d'evreux une médiathèque vie très
lumineuse un lieu culturel construit en
plein centre ville dans 95 dans un
département rural l'heure constitué de
plateaux et de vallées un cadre idéal
pour aborder le thème de cette émission
l'agriculture alors tous les samedis du
mois de novembre en effet nous vous
emmènerons avec la voix est libre dans
une ville normande 4 samedi quatre
villes et quatre thèmes avec vous
feelgood et bonjour bonjour bonjour à
tous effectivement la semaine prochaine
nous serons tout simplement à cherbourg
la cité de la mer qui sera question de
l'économie maritime il sera question
donc de la pêche bien sûr mais également
des éoliennes et pas seulement maritime
on parlera également du nucléaire c'est
important et c'est vrai que flamanville
pour lui ou palluel
eh bien ces centrales sont situées
justement en bord de mer le samedi 21
novembre
ils sont dans un autre port ou à mai au
musée d'art moderne
andré malraux et pour parler de
l'économie générale en normandie et nous
terminons notre tour de région de cette
grande région normande à alençon à la
halle aux toiles pour évoquer cette fois
l'aménagement du territoire et c'est
vrai que les collectivités territoriales
à commencer par le futur conseil de la
grande région leur monde vont devoir
s'entendre et ça c'est pas une mince
affaire on va évidemment dans l'occasion
de parler alors aujourd'hui nous parlons
donc agriculture et pour en débattre
cinq invités politiques de différents
partis on va faire les présentations
james louvain prg soit liste de gauche
ps prg
vous êtes vous-même agriculteurs dans le
calvados et vous êtes à la tête d'un
gaec avec votre frère à vos côtés le
maire d'evreux guy lefrand également
président du grand evreux agglomération
vous êtes médecin urgentiste sur la
liste d'union de la droite et du centre
normandie conquérante derrière hervé
morin face à vous françois dufour actuel
vice président europe ecologie les verts
de la région basse-normandie également
membre de la confédération paysanne
vous êtes tête de liste europe écologie
les verts dans le département de la
manche
louboutin candidat front national de
l'orne chargé de communication sur la
grille
culture et la ruralité vous êtes
vous-même également exploitant agricole
vous n'êtes plus éleveurs mais
céréaliers à saint langis les mortagne
enfin la millien ensemble pour le front
de gauche dans la manche vous êtes
retraité ancien mandataire judiciaire
pour la protection des personnes
majeures et vous êtes syndicaliste vais
pas lâcher organes l accueillir tout le
monde le regrette d'ailleurs mais pour
que le débat soit vraiment un débat il
faut que chacun puisse exprimer mais
nous écouterons des représentants de
trois liste de debout la france l'union
populaire républicaine et lutte ouvrière
un appel à contribution a été lancée sur
nos réseaux sociaux à france 3 il faut
croire que le thème de l'agriculture a
bien marché a séduit en tout cas cent
mille personnes se sont intéressées à ce
sujet et nous avons retenu quelques unes
des questions des réactions des
internautes seront donnés au cours de ce
débat alors philippe une question une
première question qui vient de moi
quels sont les enjeux de ces élections
régionales des enjeux très importants et
malheureusement pour le moment mais
effectivement france 3 va essayé
modestement de contribuer à faire en
sorte que les choses soient plus claires
faire en sorte que ces élections
régionales représentent véritablement
quelque chose pour l'ensemble de la
population de la normandie et dieu sait
si c'est important alors l'occasion tout
au long de nos émissions se rappeler et
de préciser quelles sont les
responsabilités de la région pour le
développement économique social
aujourd'hui l'agriculture et on a évoqué
d'autres thèmes et puis il ya un enjeu
politique ce sont les dernières
élections avant l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 et les élections
législatives qui vont suivre
inutile de dire y compris sur ce plateau
d'ailleurs guénaëlle que certains
certaines formations politiques veulent
faire de ces élections n'ont pas un test
est véritablement un avertissement ou
alors conforter la position actuelle du
gouvernement et du président de la
république alors field avant de lancer
le débat étudions le poids de cette
agriculture dans cette future normandie
réunifiée une région qui dispose de
produits célèbre du lait de la crème des
fromages des agneaux de pré-salé encore
du cidre des produits qui connu dans le
monde entier qui contribuent à répandre
l'idée d'une agriculture prospère et
pourtant l'agriculture a été touché en
plein coeur par la crise voyez ce
reportage d'avec son résultat une ferme
lové dans son bocage et ses pommiers
est-ce bien le vrai visage de
l'agriculture normande aujourd'hui ce
qui est sûr c'est que la normandie reste
une région avant tout agricole avec plus
de 30
cinq mille exploitations situées pour
les trois quarts dans la manche l'orne
et le calvados et 70 % de son territoire
consacré à l'agriculture
les exploitations sont de plus en plus
grosse dans les grandes plaines de leurs
de l'orne du pays de caux ou du calvados
la part consacrée aux céréales
traditionnel augmente un peu plus chaque
année et représentent aujourd'hui un
tiers du produit agricole normand à
noter tout de même une spécialité en
betteraves sucrières et une pomme de
terre à la mode
la grande normandie c'est aussi et
surtout une première place sur le podium
français des producteurs de lin quand la
première région de france la haute
s'unit avec la quatrième la basse ça
donne 38 mille hectares qui ont pour
premier client la chine
la normandie est elle donc devenu avant
tout une terre de grandes cultures
c'est l'une des difficultés pointées
aujourd'hui du doigt par les
observateurs la part de culture
s'accroît parce que pas des agriculteurs
quand ils peuvent le faire et qu'ils s'y
retrouvent pas beaucoup en rentabilité
avec les productions animales
ben il opte plutôt pour le se simplifier
des systèmes sur des productions
végétales
car il y à bien dans le panier agricole
normand l'élevage est un troupeau qui
occupe la deuxième place française
l'empreinte laitière est toujours aussi
forte et peut-être encore plus dans
certaines zones de la manche ou du
calvados
et oui comment imaginer une norme en dix
ans et fromage au lait de vache qui
représente un quart de la production
nationale censée yaourt fabriqué surtout
en haute et sans sa crème et sondeurs
produit essentiellement en basse des
éleveurs qui traverse on le sait une
crise sans précédent et qui attendent
plus que jamais un soutien des
politiques
la filière porcine se retrouvent
aujourd'hui face à de nombreux défis
elle a pourtant une place à défendre une
troisième sur le podium français alors
d'autres chiffres pour compléter ce
tableau ils viennent de la chambre
régionale d'agriculture qui donc il ya
de la haute et la basse normandie les
revenus de la ferme normande sont en
baisse c'est une estimation -18% la
crise de l'élevage est donc passée par
là et d'après le ministère de
l'agriculture 10 % des exploitations
d'élevage pourrait fermer soit entre 22
et 25 mille ferme au bord du dépôt de
bilan ça c'est en france
la révolte des agriculteurs a débuté en
basse normandie cet été au mois de
juillet
et on se souvient du blocage des grandes
surfaces des routes mais également de
l'arrivée express de stéphane le foll
pour calmer les esprits puis à la
rentrée détracteurs en marche vers paris
pour rencontrer de nouveau stéphane le
foll détracteurs qu'on a retrouvé
ensuite jusqu'à bruxelles et la crise
n'est pas finie
françois dufour vous êtes donc candidat
europe ecologie les verts actuels vice
président en charge de l'agriculture en
basse normandie la région joue un rôle
important dans l'agriculture puisqu'elle
gère les faits à des relais fonds
européen agricole pour le développement
rural en amande il enveloppe et 204
millions d'euros 308 millions d'euros
sur la période 2014 2020
comment la région peut aider les
agriculteurs la région aide les
agriculteurs en étant aujourd'hui depuis
un an maintenant autorités de gestion de
ces fonds européens les fonds
structurels la région normandie une
politique agricole actuellement qui
permet à la fois de soutenir et
d'orienter et de dd la structuration des
filières et des laits politique
d'installation aider aussi à faire en
sorte que l'agriculture puisse s'insérer
dans le territoire en tenant compte des
aléas que ce soient les aléas
économiques les aléas sociaux la
transmission des exploitations et des
outils très importants existent
actuellement à la fois pour rapprocher
les jeunes en quête d'une terre ou d'une
exploitation et des agriculteurs qui
aspirent à l'âge de la retraite à partir
dignement et à renouveler l'exploitation
la région aujourd'hui qui représente
l'agriculture qui représente pour cette
région un atout extrêmement important
très riche de ses diversités doit
continuer à évoluer dans un sens ou avec
ses fonds structurels européens
eh bien nous puissions asseoir beaucoup
plus économiquement sur le territoire
cette agriculture très forte avec ce
qu'on peut appeler une triple
performance économique sociale
environnementale et faire en sorte
d'essayer d'essayer pas toujours évident
de pallier à une agriculture qui est
complètement déconnecté au plan mondial
hélas il ya une globalisation des
échanges qui date depuis le traité de
marrakech de 1994 qui a mis toutes les
agricultures du monde
2 en concurrence d'une certaine manière
abaissement des droits de douane et
autres et donc lui fait que nous n'ayons
plus aujourd'hui de d'outils de gestion
de régulation la fin des quotas laitiers
depuis trois mois quatre mois en france
en europe pardon et aujourd'hui on l'a
bien vu souvent une agriculture qui
lorsqu elle s'exporte le marché mondial
de manière non élaboré c'est à dire en
produits bruts des céréales du lait brut
qui ne trouve pas preneur directement
est aux mains des traders
et c'est cette politique là des traders
à l'échelle mondiale qui vient en effet
boomerang fixer le prix intérieurs payés
aux producteurs
c'est complexe mais les producteurs en
savent réellement aujourd'hui parce
qu'ils le ressentent
d'où votre reportage les agriculteurs
dans la rue qui peine qui n'ont plus de
revenus
ayrault aujourd'hui les régions doivent
consolider les exploitations agricoles
pour faire face à cela mais elle a ses
régions n'ont pas le pouvoir de re
décidé à l'échelle mondiale que des
outils de gestion et de régulation
viennent autour de la fixation un peu
d'une nouvelle politique agricole
planétaire monsieur le front la coutume
de dire à tort ou à raison d'ailleurs
que les agriculteurs en tout cas ceux
qui sont au nombre de 6 ticks et
organisations syndicales des fdsea
fédération départementale des syndicats
d'exploitants agricoles sont plutôt de
votre bord on a quand même une
impression cet été et à la rentrée comme
l'évoqué le temps révèle que les choses
reconnaît pas mal évolué et que tout le
monde est un petit peu perdues et si on
reprend le les tracts et la présentation
de votre programme pour la région à
droite au centre et à droite on voit
monsieur morin par exemple dire l
agriculture est mal organisé c'est
beaucoup trop structuré mais de façon
étriqué et parfois on a un peu
l'impression de lire un tract de vos
adversaires politiques
qu'en est il exactement et pour
reprendre ce que disait l'autre
interlocuteur tout à l'heure qu'est ce
qui peut être fait au niveau de la
région pour que ça aille mieux alors je
crois qu'effectivement la région ne peut
pas tout faire mais la région peut faire
beaucoup
quand faut-il que la région s'en donne
les moyens aujourd'hui la région haute
normandie par exemple n'a toujours pas
validé son pdr son programme de
développement rural
nous sommes très en retard alors que
vous disiez vous même nous sommes dans
une région très agricole aujourd'hui le
ce qui doit aider les agriculteurs n'est
pas mis en route par la région donc ça
c'est déjà un premier retard nous avons
d'autres aides très particulière
comme les marchés par exemple les
mesures agro environnementales qui est
un programme de 2015 à 2020 déjà 70%
aujourd'hui de l'aide à l'élevage ont
été consommés alors même que nous ne
sommes qu'au début de la première année
et donc tout ça pour dire que nous
devons j'entendais parler de triple
performance nous devons effectivement
faire vivre cette triple performance
économique sociale environnementale mais
dans le bon ordre en commençant par
l'économique
nous devons arrêter cette inflation de
normes d'accentuation des charges
sociales c'est ça aujourd'hui qui
détruit les agriculteurs c'est ça
aujourd'hui qui fait chuter le revenu
net moyen pour chaque agriculteur sur
des fermes qui sont petites la moyenne
en normandie reste autour de 55 56
hectares donc nous avons besoin de
libérer l'économique et pour ça nous
devons absolument renforcer d'une part
les circuits courts c'est-à-dire le
marché local et nous c'est ce que nous
avons commencé à faire à evreux dans le
cadre de l'unité centrale de production
dans le cas de la mise en place d'un
drive pour les agriculteurs dans le plat
dans le cas des fêtes normande qui
permet aux producteurs locaux de venir
directement et nous devons nous
développer à l'export
je pense que nous aurons l'occasion d'en
reparler mais aider les agriculteurs ce
n'est pas les assistés c'est leur
permettre de se développer
économiquement je prends est juste un
exemple le port de rouen aujourd'hui
pour les céréaliers doit être recreuser
nous risquons la fermeture à terme du
port de rouen
ça c'est du rôle de la région c'est un
rôle majeur d'infrastructures qui permet
de faire gagner au moins 10 % de revenus
pour les céréaliers alain millien du
front de gauche on entendu la détresse
des agriculteurs qui demandent une juste
rémunération de leur travail notamment
cet été
voulez-vous la fin de la dérégulation
des marchés vous pensez qu'il jouerait
encadrer le travail donc je crois que ce
serait une erreur de faire croire aux
paysans que moins de réglementation
permettra de sauver leur métier ce
serait une erreur parce que d'une part
il tout à fait normal que lorsqu'un
secteur est subventionnée et bien il ya
des contraintes aussi bien en termes de
sécurité sécurité alimentaire en termes
de sécurité environnementale et je crois
que ce serait une erreur aussi de croire
que la solution par rapport avec la
culture normande avec la culture
française et même européenne
c'est
d'aller vers le plus de productivité
plus de compétitivité au niveau mondial
ça sera une erreur parce que je crois
que la crise on parle de la crise à
l'école mais on pourrait dire les crises
agricoles ont parsemé toute l'histoire
de la pac que s'ils attaquent a été créé
c'était avec l'illusion que
l'agriculture française pour être
compétitive et lorsque l'om c'est les
tonneaux de l'onem cesser les mêmes que
l'on rencontre à la tête de la fnsea par
exemple les tenants de l'open de l'om
c'est son pour le libéralisme dans le
marché intérieur et contre libéral 10
mai pour des règles dans le marché
mondial avec tous les risques que cela
représente pour les agricultures
vivrières des pays émergents je crois
que la crise qu'on connaît au niveau des
migrations actuellement est liée aussi
aux crises agricoles pas connu les
agricultures des pays émergents donc
nous on est pour qui une réglementation
une réglementation non pas qu'ils soient
casse pieds non pas qui est un
l'agriculture mais qui accompagne pour
qu'elle puisse apporter les garanties en
termes de sécurité alimentaire en termes
de développement du territoire etc
je crois que l'autre erreur que qui est
fait que disait monsieur le maire c'est
en fait derrière ces propos c'était de
dire qu'il faut aller vers la
concentration des exploitations
agricoles
ces terribles faits par rapport à ça
parce que ça veut dire que les
exploitations
or on a un bilan et un compte
d'exploitation qui sera portée par les
investissements c'est l'impossibilité de
faire les sessions et la reprise par des
jeunes agriculteurs
moi je crois que la région et notamment
avec la nouvelle pac et aussi avec le
doublement et voir plus de tout ce qui
tourne autour des aides au développement
rural a des moyens proposés par rapport
à ça et notamment aussi en confortant
eh bien les aides qu'ils retournent vers
une rigueur mieux mieux dimensionnés une
agriculture basée sur les herbages
notamment je pense qu'on reviendra là
dessus on va écouter à présent à noah
seule candidate pour debout la france
dans le calvados salle est agricultrice
maire de son elle dénonce elle aussi le
rôle de bruxelles on écoute
déjà c'est de sauver nos agriculteurs en
normandie
aujourd'hui ne vivent plus de leur
métier il leur faut avant tout un prix
rémunérateur
donc pour cela il n'y a pas que la
normandie qui pourra résoudre le
problème puisque le problème se situe au
niveau de l'union européenne
il faut travailler avec nos partenaires
européens souvent debout la france et
contre l'europe non on est contre une
union européenne qui nous impose des
choses avec des gens qui ne sont pas
élus qui sont derrière un ordinateur et
qui prennent des sites décision sans
connaître le terrain nous on connaît le
terrain
donc il faut absolument rappelé le rôle
de l'agriculteur qui a un rôle
nourricier
nous sommes avant tout là pour nourrir
la planète donc il faut réguler les
quantités nous sommes partis vers un
libéralisme total qui nous tue
aujourd'hui jacques louvet est ce qu'on
peut dire que on entend beaucoup parler
d'europe dans cette dans ce début de
campagne pour les élections régionales
est ce que ces élections régionales
c'est pas un peu le match retour des
élections européennes dans le sens où on
a un peu l'impression que beaucoup aimé
autour de cette table on en entendra
probablement d'autres propos considère
que l'europe bien finalement la castou
empêche les gens de se développer etc
quelle est votre position il est clair
que l'europe joue un grand rôle
on peut s'apercevoir qu'au niveau du
revenu nous avons un revenu de la ferme
normande qui se quittent à peu près de
700 millions d'euros qui composaient
pratiquement 100% des aides européennes
c'est à dire que si l'on retire les
aides européennes aux aides directes
premier second pays et nous arrivons à
un revenu égal à zéro c'est le premier
point
moi j'aimerais revenir sur les propos de
monsieur monsieur le franc ce que je
regrette c'est quand que depuis 2008 par
rapport au gouvernement précédent nous
avons eu comme des actes majeurs de
dérégulation qui nous ont quand beaucoup
pénalisé au niveau de l'agriculture
moi je suis agriculteur dans le bocage
virois j'ai pu constater que depuis 2008
de nombreuses
ont été prises qui contribue à
libéraliser je prends un exemple la loi
que les éleveurs appelait la loi michel
edouard leclerc c'est à dire la loi de
modernisation de l'économie voulu par
nicolas sarkozy je crois en 2008 c'est
une loi vraiment scélérate qui nous a
assommés par rapport à la grande
distribution c'est un premier exemple la
fin françois dufour le rappelait mais la
fin des quotas laitiers fin des quotas
laitiers qui bon et c'était décision
européenne c'est clair c'est pas le
gouvernement sarkozy qui l'a voulu seul
mais le gouvernement sarkozy l'a quand
même accompagné fortement par ailleurs
moi c'est ce qui me va aussi poser souci
c'est la dérégulation au niveau des
structures du contrôle des structures à
partir d'un moment on a dit ban
laissons-les les fermes s'agrandir et on
s'aperçoit aujourd'hui quand on regarde
clairement moi je suis élu à la chambre
d'agriculture je vois les comptes
annuels de la ferme normande
on s'aperçoit que ce n'est pas parce que
nous nous augmentons la surface d
exposition école que leurs revenus aient
nécessairement meilleur on est à -18%
donc nous avons un contexte qui malgré
tout favorable en termes de conditions
pédoclimatiques nous avons un super
climat de très belles terres parmi les
meilleurs termes d'europe sur certains
sur certains terroirs et malgré tout
nous avons un niveau de revenu qu'il a
ses faveurs il faut aller chercher
pourquoi alors c'est vrai qu'on va
parler des effets de l'europe on va
parler des effets nationaux mais il ya
aussi des effets qui sont régionaux et
qui sont assez prégnant jeu j'en citerai
quelques-uns le président bové avait
commandé en son temps ou président du
rond sur la basse-normandie à une étude
sur les coûts de production et à cette
étude il avait été noté c'était avec les
conseils régionaux les csr de pays de
loire et de bretagne pour voir quels
étaient les coûts de production on
s'apercevait caen en normandie nous
avions par exemple le prix d'un prix du
lait très élevé par rapport à la moyenne
française très élevés sur des
territoires de plein on dort et
territoires de montagne et malgré cela
nous avions un revenu qui était très
faible pourquoi on a essayé de regarder
un petit peu dans le détail et on s'est
aperçu très vite nous avions des coûts
de production beaucoup trop élevé et ça
c'est vraiment un cancer niveau de notre
agriculture c'est d'avoir des coûts de
production beaucoup trop élevé alors il
y a eu aussi des mesures fiscales par
l'ancien gouvernement qui ont été mises
en place notamment ceux qu'on appelle
les déductions fiscales pour
investissement quitter
dur mais qui était aussi très très nocif
pour l'agriculteur parce que l'année une
certaine et il avait tendance à investir
et ensuite il était fortement endetté et
c'est ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure nous avons aussi une agriculture
qui est assez peu performants en termes
économiques donc tous ces éléments-là
faut qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
situation relativement difficile
un autre point qui est là nous sommes en
région rurale dans l'eure mais aussi une
région aussi qui est soumise à pression
urbaine comme en seine maritime comme
dans le calvados un tout petit bout -
peut-être dans la manche est et dans
l'orne
mais nous avons une pression foncière
tous les vrais dit moins importante et
qui coûte cher aussi aux agriculteurs
donc l'investissement foncier est assez
est assez important dernier point
kim qui me semble important aussi c'est
le renchérissement des matières
premières
premières on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que
quand on fait des élevages nous sommes
dans une crise une crise principalement
d'élevage une crise d'élevage avec des
matières premières qui deviennent de
plus en plus onéreuses notamment le
cours des céréales et c'est vrai qu'à ce
niveau là ça pose un gros souci le matin
du front national à le monde paysan
semble être une terre assez fertile pour
le front national
on a vu par exemple que yannick bodin
dans la manche de la coordination rurale
avait accueilli marine le pen en mars
dernier dans sa ferme il a dit qu'il
voterait front national qu'est ce que
vous proposez vous posez les cultes
heures les agriculteurs normands sont
les premiers victimes de cette crise
agricole qui frappe et qui fera peut
doublement qu'ils frappent les
producteurs au début de la chaîne
alimentaire puisque nous n'arrivons plus
à vivre de l'élevage nous n'arrivons
plus à vivre de notre travail et à
l'autre extrémité de la chaîne
concomitamment un grand nombre de nos
concitoyens qui se serrent la ceinture
sont obligés d'acheter des produits de
mauvaise qualité
donc nous nous sommes vraiment là devant
une double crise qui
donc il faut trouver les solutions et je
ne crois pas que
le conseil régional lui à lui seul
résoudre à le résoudre le problème en
réalité la crise agricole est une crise
qui se dé qui doit se décliner au niveau
national au niveau européen les
provinces telles attaques pour la
politique les promesses des promesses
des différents candidats ici en
normandie
non pas de sens ils sont déconnectés des
politiques agricoles nationales de la
politique agricole européenne parce
qu'en réalité on peut faire tout ce
qu'on veut et mettre sur pied tous les
plans des deux cons qu'on souhaite dans
l'élevage ou dans la filière de la
viande dans la filière du porc toutes
ces aides ne sont que des que des
emplâtres sur des jambes de bois puisque
seul levier du conseil régional en fait
et le font et font que repousser
l'échéance puisque en réalité on est
livré au marché mondial on a ouvert les
frontières nous mettant en concurrence
avec des gens qui n'ont ni la même
législation fiscale ni la même
législation sanitaire social et droit du
travail et qui pose de graves problèmes
dans notre métier alors monsieur le
français a tout petits pour difficile de
top parole je disais il ya quelques
instants pour le constater de vous c'est
vrai que l'europe est omniprésente dans
ce débat sur les régionales
alors j'aimerais quand même qu'on dise
un moule a récemment à maromme il ya la
coopérative laitière normande a inauguré
une nouvelle section de transformation
du lait très performante mais qui ne
peut fonctionner qu'à partir d'un nombre
important de litres de lait alors est-ce
qu'il ya pas cette spirale qui évoqué
tout à l'heure monsieur louvain en dix
ans on a trop libéralisé du temps
monsieur sarkozy clairement c'est ce que
monsieur je vous disais est ce qu il
est-ce qu'on n'ait pas pris dans un
piège parce que les agriculteurs ne sont
pas finalement piégé dans ce système
toujours plus toujours plus toujours
plus je précise quand même que la
coopérative laitière à travailler avec
l'europe et avec le conseil régional qui
a co subventionner cette opération
écoutez je pense qu'on peut tout mettre
sur le dos des gouvernements précédents
sur le dos de l'europe mais on réglera
pas le problème nous sommes ici parce
que nous avons la volonté de gérer une
région
et quand on a la volonté de gérer une
région on se donne les moyens et on
essaie de trouver des solutions
une des propositions phare d'hervé morin
c'est justement de favoriser la mise en
place d'organisations puissantes au
niveau des producteurs
parce que comment vous êtes vous même
c'est absolument indispensable pour
pouvoir s'en sortir
nous devons continuer à travailler sur
les infrastructures
j'étais il ya quelques jours dans une
coopérative de là et il m'expliquait
qu'aujourd'hui il quitte de plus en plus
le port du havre pour aller vers
dunkerque où les ports du nord de
l'europe parce qu'on l'a on les fait
attendre plus de quinze jours pour
pouvoir embarquer leur là alors qu'ils
mettent 24 48 heures dans le nord de
l'europe
ça c'est un travail de la région qui est
très pragmatique et très précis nous ne
sommes pas dans des grandes envolées
lyriques contre l'europe
nous nous sommes sur des choses
particulièrement pragmatique dokoui nous
pouvons réussir ce genre de chose nous
devons aussi dans les po dead dont nous
bénéficions de l'europe ces quelques
millions d'euros quand même dont nous
bénéficions il faut les réorienter il
faut les reflets chez aujourd'hui on met
tout sur le bio le bio c'est très bien
mais c'est une niche il ne niche ça ne
suffit pas à faire vivre une région
entière surtout la première région
agricole sur beaucoup de sujets tels que
la normandie donc oui nous devons reflet
chez une partie de l'argent qu'ils
étaient dirigés vers le bio vers les mae
sai dont je parlais tout à l'heure de
manière à aider les éleveurs de manière
à les aider à se mettre aux normes à se
mettre en place et au delà de ça le
travail de la région c'est aussi de
travailler sur le social devons parler
de triple performance n'oublions pas
aussi la performance sociale et la
performance sociale par exemple c'est de
se rappeler que le bien-être de
l'agriculteur ça passe aussi peut-être
de temps en temps avant le bien-être
animal alors le matin vous disiez que
vous aviez cesser votre activité
d'éleveur que vous ne vous consacriez
plus que maintenant aux céréales est ce
que vous nous expliquer ce qui vous a
mis tout à fait comme beaucoup
d'éleveurs du perche
comme beaucoup d'éleveurs normand gibus
c'est l'élevage parce que
j'irai plus loin que ce qu'elle dit
monsieur tout à l'heure si on supprime
les aides de la ferme normande le compte
n'est pas héros le compte est
déficitaire
le conte est difficile ça veut dire que
les aides ne suffisent plus et j'ai dû
cesser l'élevage oui parce que quand on
est chef d'entreprise il faut prendre
des décisions
quand le moment est venu il faut pas
attendre trop et donc je suis céréaliers
mais céréalier dans le perche c'est
plutôt une région d'élevage c'est
dommage de labourer les prairies c'est
dommage de faire du blé on aurait pu
élever des vaches
c'est un beau métier c'est un métier
qu'on aime est ce un métier dont on ne
peut plus vivre et c'est le drame de
beaucoup de beaucoup d'éleveurs normand
7 grammes de beaucoup d'éleveurs de la
région qui sont aujourd'hui en
redressement judiciaire ou en
liquidation
françois dufour c'est les yeux au ciel
c'est à dire quand vous parlez de
plaisait d'aller au bio oui je pense que
monsieur lefranc la non vous n'avez pas
les bons chiffres parce que le plan de
développement rural de vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure pour la normandie pour
les deux normandie réunifiée au 1er
janvier le plan développement rural qui
viendrait donc validé par bruxelles nous
a fixé des règles un peu en termes
d'équilibré entre la part qui peut aller
qui doit aller à l'installation des
jeunes agriculteurs
la part qui va vers le plan
d'investissement pour les exploitations
agricoles la part qui va donc à partir
de la filière par filière et notamment
vers l'agriculture biologique et la part
qui va vers les mesures agro
environnementales et climatiques
donc nous avons détourné de respecter
ces aides doivent servir effectivement à
accompagner les agriculteurs pour
essayer comme je l ai dit tout à l'heure
de reconsolider les exploitations
agricoles et j'aime sauvé a parlé tout à
l'heure que l'agriculture était souvent
dépendante notamment des matières
premières effectivement en normandie
nous avons des atouts
ça a été dit à tous notamment vis-à-vis
du climat vis-à-vis de politique de
qualité de race locale
la vache normande par exemple qui permet
d'avoir un lait très riche en taux
protéique quant aux matières grasses et
qui permet d'avoir les appellations
d'origine protégée notamment les
fromages la crème d'isigny tout cela
c'est quelque chose que nous avons dans
les mains c'est pas quelque chose qu'il
faut apporter
nous l'avons et là où nous pouvons
renforcer nos exploitations c'est de
faire en sorte et bien qu'on soit moins
dépendant
en du marché extérieur notamment des
protéines que nous apportons pour
équilibrer les rations n'a beaucoup de
maïs maintenant dans nos parcelles les
vaches mangent du maïs beaucoup dans les
fermes pour équilibrer la ration va
chercher du soja américain canadiens
brésiliens et argentins
ce soja peut changer huit fois par nuit
ou par jour de prix selon ce que les
spéculateurs mondiaux et traders dont
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure peuvent faire
un mois après que nous ayons arrêter les
quotas laitiers en avril dernier un mois
après le lait qui va sur le marché
mondial je les dis je le répète qu'il ne
trouve pas preneur une bonne
valorisation et la main des traders ces
deux cancers la cde gangrène la sont en
train de détruire nos économies dont il
faut effectivement remettre des outils
de régulation mais en même temps il faut
hélas nous avons des atouts en normandie
faire un vrai plan protéines pour
développer les protéines que sont la
féverole les poils heulin nous l'avons
premier régions normandes première
région au monde en exposant chine et on
exporte mais on a la graine est donc
tout cela permet d'eric de rééquilibrer
les rations les agriculteurs le savent
dans le bocage avec les luzernes les
trêves dans les prairies ça c'est notre
richesse et on est et on sait on a des
chiffres dans les réseaux agricoles et
les chambres d'agriculture les civam où
les réseaux bio tout le monde sait que
dans les exploitations où on essaie de
trouver le bon équilibre
on a des coûts de production bien
maîtrisé ça n'enlève rien au fait que la
crise est en train de détruire les
revues mais le but d'une région c'est de
justement injecter des aides avec des
critères qui vont permettre de
consolider les exploitations et dernier
point
dernier point la restructuration
agricole qui dure depuis 50 ans 80 % des
agriculteurs ont disparu chaque fois que
sur quatre fermes qui disparaissent pour
aller en retraite ou parce qu'il ya des
difficultés
vous en avez simplement une qui se
réinstallent et les 3 qui arrête ça va à
l'agrandissement ya rarement une
création de main d'oeuvre
mais ce coup de reprise des terres et de
ce qui amène dans la ferme à changer les
normes la ferme avait d'énormes pour 120
bovins elle était dans ses normes
elle passe à 160 bovins elle est à 40 go
20 au dessus il faut passer dans l'autre
nord change et en même temps elle achète
du foncier qui est spéculée comme l'a
dit j'ai trouvé tout cela
anéantie
quelque part le revenu paysan est donc
cette spirale là n'a pas beaucoup
d'avenir pour le revenu agricole
monsieur milhas une question un peu plus
politique vous ne partez pas juillet au
combat avec le parti radical de gauche
le parti socialiste et les divers gauche
de même d'ailleurs que l'europe écologie
les verts ça c'est quand même
relativement nouveau dans le sens où
dans le sens où vous avez gouverner la
région basse normandie alors un jour
haute-normandie ensemble jusqu'à présent
qu'est ce qui fait que vous n'êtes pas
d'accord entre vous ou alors si la mort
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec vous
attend dès le premier tour pour vous
conter d'entraînement spécifiquement sur
l'agriculture
je crois que nous avons à peu près le
même discours à quelques nuances près
avec eux élevé je crois que dire qu'il
faut recentrer l'agriculture ces
produits de qualité que effectivement
l'agriculture est porteur d'emplois
porteurs de diversité sociale porter des
des réponses adaptées à l'environnement
l'aménagement du territoire ça c'est
juste bon politiquement pourquoi on se
présente seul c'est parce que nous avons
un gouvernement qui est porté par parti
socialiste avec une
qui a été porté aussi avec les voix de
élevé qui a quitté gouvernement a choisi
une politique d'austérité politique
d'austérité qui trouve ses limites dans
nos régions dans nos professions et
c'est sûr de protection sociale
effectivement il faut peser
certes pour recréer une unité unité sur
un programme anti austérité et on peut
voir que lorsque l'on décline tous les
programmes économiques socio
environnemental etc
eh bien on a des réponses adaptées alors
après au deuxième tour on verra en
fonction d'une part du rapport de force
puisque les élections politiques ceux ci
un rapport de force voir un peu où en
sont les affaires et puis les alliances
qui peuvent exister qui peuvent être en
dehors des schémas qu'on a connu
historiquement aussi parce que nous
avons des réponses différentes et je
sens dans ce qui se dit actuellement des
réponses qu'on peut retrouver avec
d'autres organisations politiques qui
ont choisi de partir seuls aujourd'hui
pour reconstruire effectivement des
réponses attendues par la population qui
est un refus net de la série t parce que
le choix c'est est ce qu'on pense qu' il
n'y a pas d'autre choix que d'accepter
les règles du libéralisme et c'est
notamment les discussions qui au niveau
de la ftf tàu gouvernement est engagé ou
s'il ya possibilité d'avoir une
politique qui soit sociale que
environnants rien environnementale oui
j'aimerais réagir aux propos de monsieur
c'est vrai que je rappellerai quand même
nous faire une petite confidence que au
sein des deux exécutifs régionaux
actuellement les deux vice présidents
chargés de l'agriculture et des affaires
rurales
ce sont claude taleb pour les ottomans
10 et françois pour la basse-normandie
donc je peux vous dire aussi que les
deux présidents actuels des deux régions
sont assez fiers du bilan sur
l'agriculture et notamment du travail de
leur vice président et je le dis sans
aucune arrière pensée
je le dis parce que nos adversaires nous
nous sommes dans une majorité qui est
plurielle aujourd'hui au sein des
exécutifs et nous espérons bien
continuer à travailler avec cette
majorité plurielle et faire en sorte que
l'on puisse bien mené le projet normand
ça c'est le
le premier point je souhaiterais comme
vous rassurer nos adversaires
aujourd'hui nous ce sont vers sert
évidemment de droite républicaine on va
dire les républicains lui dès le modem
et la majorité donc autour de d'hervé
morin évidemment l'extrême droite
nos adversaires ne sont pas là alors je
tiens à vous rassurer je tiens aussi à
rassurer mon voisin monsieur le franc
par rapport à la bio et aux circuits
courts
il est clair qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
nicolas meyer signal quelqu'un de
pragmatique et qui considèrent que le la
bio et le circuit court ne résoudrons
pas tous les problèmes
il y est très favorable il veut que cela
se développe avec peut-être revoir aussi
j'ai travaillé un peu plus à ce niveau
là sur l'image de la normandie il faut
retravailler cette image parce qu'elle
n'est pas suffisante et je crois que
même le concept bourde de gourmandise
n'est peut-être pas et peut-être à
revoir et améliorer
il a été créé il ya 15 ans mais je pense
qu'il ya quelque chose à revoir nicolas
meyer signaler aussi très très très
attaché à la formation des jeunes
agriculteurs à la formation à travers
les lycées agricoles à travers les
chèques formation qui sont destinés
aussi aux agriculteurs à la formation
initiale continue par apprentissage et
il envie aussi de mettre beaucoup de
moyens dessus sur les mae sai je sais
pas qui en a parlé mais il est clair que
nous sommes ceux des mesures
agro-environnementales je suis quelqu'un
d'aller le sait elles sont climatique a
nommé quelqu'un l'a oublié tout à
l'heure je pense que c'est important si
on veut qu'elle soit aussi intéressante
il faut qu'elles soient aussi pour un
plus grand nombre et à ce niveau là haut
niveau au sein de notre liste nous
travaillons aussi pour réfléchir
justement à faire en sorte qu'il y ait
une accessibilité qui sont importantes
pas du saupoudrage mais une politique
efficace et dernier pas que je voulais
souligner sur les fonds publics nous
avons nicolas meyer on signale quelqu'un
qui est très soucieux des deniers
publics
je rappellerai que nous sommes sur deux
régions aujourd'hui qui sont les mieux
gérées de france
c'est aussi au crédit des équipes
sortantes par rapport aux
investissements
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure du
surinvestissement agriculteurs il est
important qu'il y ait des aides qu'ils
soient concentrés sur les
investissements collectifs auprès
d'agriculteurs ce qui était fait
notamment principalement basse normandie
un peu moins haute normandie il est
important qu'il y ait un axe fort là
dessus pour que l'on puisse bien gérer
les fonds publics
et je dis moi je dis toujours
je le rappelle dans mes réunions de
secteurs actuellement sur le territoire
il est toujours plus important que la
collectivité que la puissance publique
donne 4 euros un groupe d'agriculteurs
qu'un euro à cinq agriculteurs c'est
simpliste mais bon c'est de la bonne
gestion et nicola meier de signal il est
très attaché monsieur alain contant dar
al voilà vous vouliez réagir et après on
posera une question qui est intense et à
une question d'un internaute puisque
besoins en doute quand même se sont
mobilisés sur ce débat et on les en
remercie monsieur laurent voulzy réagir
tout roulait juste un mot vous savez
savoir si les verts le front de gauche
le quai c'est tout son sens pas ensemble
aujourd'hui ils gouvernent ensemble au
premier tour ils gouverneront plus au
deuxième tour éventuellement peut-être
je crois honnêtement on s'en fout
aujourd'hui ce qui est important c'est
de savoir est ce que vous êtes d'accord
sur des mesures pragmatiques les uns les
autres
est ce que vous êtes d'accord pour
développer la recherche par exemple en
plasturgie où il ya quand même beaucoup
de travail à mener là dessus qu'ils
pourront aider justement à la fois sûre
en matière d'écologie en matière
d'économie à ce que vous êtes d'accord
pour travailler pour accompagner les
agriculteurs sur la biomasse est ce que
vous êtes d'accord pour mettre en place
un fonds d aide à l'installation en
particulier des jeunes agriculteurs est
ce que vous êtes capables d'aider à la
protection des zones et des terres
agricoles à evreux je me bats pour que
la gare reste là où elle est pour éviter
de perdre des dizaines d'hectares
aujourd'hui qui sont utilisés pour
l'agriculture
ce sont ces réponses là que les
agriculteurs attendent alors nous
effectivement au centre au centre et à
droite
nous avions fait l'unité et nous avons
dès le premier tour dès le départ mis en
place un programme qui nous correspond
sur lequel nous voulons nous battre et
nous défendre et ne pas avoir plusieurs
programmes différents qui éventuellement
peut-être fusionneront entre le 6 et le
13 décembre monsieur boutin d'abord une
question d'internaute juste un an
puisque on a eu beaucoup de
contributions 100 mille personnes qui
sont connectés sur nos réseaux sociaux
comment les producteurs de lait normands
comptent ils échapper rouleau
compresseur de l'agriculture américaine
qui ont de plus grosses exploitations
des normes amoindri si l'accord de libre
échange entre les états unis et l'europe
est mis en place d'une bonne question et
le front national
on me dira c'est david étudiant accorde
le front national fera tout ce qui est
en soi possibilité pour que le traité de
libre échange ne soit pas signé
malheureusement
si les signes et les projections de par
exemple l'interprofession bovine après a
programmé la baisse du revenu des
éleveurs serait de 40% sont des
centaines de milliers de tonnes de
viande qu'ils vont envoyer en notre
marché qui viendront du canada ou des
états-unis et qui vont achever ce qui
reste de la filière de l'élevage en
normandie et dans le reste de la france
voilà donc je pense que nous sommes pas
les seuls mais nous c'est pas la
compétence du conseil régional mais nous
nous opposerons de toutes nos forces à
ce traité de libre-échange qui va finir
d'achever la ruralité parce que la crise
de l'agriculture est aussi liée à la
crise de la ruralité du départ des
services publics de la mort du petit
commerce et des tpe et des pme
écoutez vous dit pas les seuls au front
national à craindre le développement
justement de ce libre échange qui peut
exister entre l'amérique et l'europe
et puis à craindre également le
développement tout simplement de
l'europe
alors on va écouter deux représentants
de deux listes c'est parce qu'elle le
bella qui représente lutte ouvrière en
premier et juste après le jean
christophe loutre de l'union populaire
républicaine alors ils sont pas du tout
du même bord le premier est d'extrême
gauche l'autre même s'ils s'en défend et
plutôt deux côtés de l'échiquier
politique mais par moments on a
l'impression quand même que leur
discours se réunissent on les écoute
tout de suite dans l'agriculture il ya
un peu d'eux agriculture il ya la grande
agriculture agroalimentaire et c'est
vrai il ya aussi des paysans qui ont des
difficultés et qui sont sous la coupe
des grandes surfaces à commercial qui
leur imposent des revenus mais indécent
et cette partie de l'agriculture qui est
proche en fait du monde du travail ce
sont des travailleurs agriculteurs eh
bien oui on est de leur côté parce que
nous avons aussi les mêmes
revendications en matière d'agriculture
c'est bruxelles qui décide donc il y à
des règlements qui nous impose
aujourd'hui de faire en sorte que les
agriculteurs soient plus tourné vers la
grande production un productivisme
exacerbée et ce faisant on est confronté
en plus avec des concurrents européens
qui ont en plus problématique de main
d'oeuvre beaucoup meilleur marché que la
nôtre donc c'est le serpent qui se mord
la queue c'est qu'on est confronté à une
auto concurrence européenne on va
découvrir à présent une ferme un peu à
part une ferme d'avenir que la liste
d'ailleurs europe ecologie les verts a
mis en avant lors de sa campagne le
petit changeons c'est une ferme
expérimentale ouverte en 2007 dans la
manche avranches quatre personnes y
travaillent sur seulement 18 hectares
avec des impératifs autonomie
inventivité même un petit luxe un jour
de un week-end de congés un week-end sur
deux c'est un reportage de clamart et
pio et du al ahmar ce serait donc une
ferme d'avenir une exploitation modèle
pourtant bien loin des canons
productiviste de l'époque tout repos et
la wii les petits donc on a trente trois
chèvres laitières
en fait on a un troupeau qui est
dimensionné à nos terres et aux
fourrages qu'on peut produire pour
lumière fergie
tout repose sur ce principe la ferme du
petit change on est autonome
les chèvres mange l'herbe les ronces et
le foin de la ferme et le lait est
transformé sur place l'autre credo c'est
la vente directe pour supprimer les
intermédiaires les fromages sont vendus
sur les marchés et dans les restaurants
la ferme produit aussi de la charcuterie
de la viande et bientôt du pain
les travaux de la boulangerie sont
précipités et avec seulement deux
hectares de blé
la ferme est autonome sa façade avec la
farine qu'on a de tenir l'année sur 120
kg en fait on est parti sur 120 kg par
semaine plus les brioches ça nous fait
ça fait en moyenne de farine on utilise
une centaine de kilos de farine par
semaine pour le pour la gorge un peu de
charges pas d'emprunts bancaires et des
produits vendus en direct la ferme et
rentable elle fait vivre quatre
personnes avec seulement 18 hectares de
terre c'est le pétrole alimente si les
banques ne sais pas quoi si le
l'agrobusiness je sais pas quoi vous
disait le prix par deux et c'est nous on
n'est pas touché
donc non demain après demain on est
encore là on sera toujours là parce
qu'on est on est avant tout autonome et
imaginatif ne dit on diversifie
on va jusqu'au bout de notre démarche
dernière précision chacun ici s'octroie
un week-end sur deux et cinq semaines de
congés par an la ferme offre si le luxe
de pouvoir mener une vie normale
le méthane question puisque vous êtes en
déficit de parole pour l'instant est
question internautes de nicolas du havre
les futurs élus vont ils favoriser les
circuits courts alimentaires et
promouvoir les produits frais de qualité
et de saison
bien sûr il faudra promouvoir les
filières courtes le bio dans l'objectif
je rappelle est de 20 % d'exploitations
bio en 2020 si je me trompe pas et donc
oui il met enfin en réalité c'est pas le
travail d'un agriculteur d'être bouché
ou d'être marchand de fromages vous
d'être malheureusement c'est une
situation que c'est pas l'avenir
justement de penser ce qui est après
tout le monde n'est pas fait pour ça les
agriculteurs sont faits pour produire du
blé pour produire du lait pour produire
de la viande mais tous ne sont pas
capables de le vendre et c'est très
difficile pour un agriculteur de
déplacer en région parisienne et de
vendre sa viande
voilà un programme conjoint suracheté
français oui tout à fait ce qui est
prévu tout à fait justement le conseil
régional peut un levier dans cette danse
dans cette matière puisqu'il s'agit de
démarcher des marchés publics et de la
restauration collective ou le conserver
jal doit pouvoir avoir le moyen et a le
moyen par le biais des appels d'offres
et des marchés publics de favoriser les
produits locaux de favoriser les
produits normands les produits français
mais ce milieu tout à l'heure on a
entendu monsieur le manach représente
lutte ouvrière lutte ouvrière qui a eu
deux élus il ya quelques années au sein
du conseil régional de haute normandie
on l'a entendu parler aussi des
travailleurs c'est vrai que on parle
beaucoup de ces tables et c'est normal
des agriculteurs mais 16% des emplois
industriels vient finalement on les
trouve dans l'agriculture alors que cela
mène à que parler des travailleurs vous
vous parlez des salariés et est ce que
sur le plan social là aussi il ya de
véritables drames on devenir si les
choses ne s'améliorent pas ben ben oui
bien évidemment parce que
l'agroalimentaire donc l industrie de
transformation en haute et basse
normandie représente 11 16 et 18 % à la
manoeuvre salariale
donc c'est pas rien sauf que l'on
s'aperçoit aussi que cette cette
industrie agroalimentaire d'une part
vie aussi les crises elle vit aussi une
crise de gouvernance parce que les
souvent ils sont appuyés sur un système
de coopérative mais les coopératives
abandonné les producteurs les
propriétaires de ces coopératives ont
perdu le pouvoir de gestion et de
management à ces coopératives là je
reviendrai pas sur la responsabilité des
dirigeants agricoles du syndicat
majoritaire qui effectivement on laisser
ça maintenant on peut avoir une
coopérative où il ya des fonds privés et
des fonds d'investissement et les
agriculteurs n'ont pu le moyen de peser
là dessus nous on pense qu'effectivement
il faut relancer un secteur de
transformation locale pour permettre
d'être performant sur les marchés locaux
ou nationaux
la normandie c'est quand même trois
millions cinq cent mille habitants la
france 65 millions et l'europe 500
millions je pense que on a un marché
suffisamment fort hood et marché
suffisamment fort pour ne pas faire le
jeu de
la mondialisation avec tous les risques
qui ont déjà été soutenu par rapport à
ça parce que là on fera pas le poids
donc effectivement il va il faut
relancer aider les possibilités de créer
des établissements agroalimentaire de
transformation des abattoirs etc qui
sont plus près de la production est au
plus près des marchés
je crois que la dernière enfin la
dernière fois la dernière mais quelque
chose qui illustre bien ça c'est
difficultés qu'à eues l'abattoir de
payer mieux la hyène ou effectivement
première crise la région le département
interviennent et payent notamment les
les bâtiments il ya eu effectivement un
effort de la région pour permettre la
reprise de l'aiem avec une scop etc
mais en même temps il aurait été
important que
les politiques de la région poussent
encore plus pour développer les marchés
locaux et notamment les marchés que
représentent les collectivités
territoriales etc
ça c'est des choses qui sont
certainement en chantier mais qui n'ont
pas été assez rapides
et puis l'autre chose c'était aussi la
garantie des emprunts finances etc ont
dû reprendre les repreneurs de l'aiem
donc la scop
il y a eu quand même des taux usuraires
qui ont été quasiment imposé pour la
reprise
il aurait été intéressant que la région
puisse apporter la garantie financière
pour permettre cela on a eu des réunions
communes notamment au niveau des
cantonales on a des candidats communs
avec les verts sur certains cantons où
ça a été discuté ce truc là et en même
temps les habitants trouve ça assez
logique que les politiques interviennent
concrètement pour défendre la ruralité
je voulais revenir aussi parce que
j'avais levé la main s'est excusé moi
j'arrive pour 30 secondes c'était par
rapport à la biomasse idée intéressante
en soi mais ça dépend quelle structure
agricole on veut demain si c'est pour
créer des entreprises telles que les
1000 vaches à amiens ou en fait
l'agriculture et les produits agricoles
deviennent un sous produit de l'énergie
ça nous va pas du tout ça donc ça veut
dire aussi qu'il faut regarder comment
on peut utiliser les fonds du
développement rural qui sont quand même
qu'elles ont plus que doublé avec une
nouvelle pac pour voir comment
politiquement peut intervenir par
rapport à ça une question d'une
internaute avoue guy lefrand d'evelyne
gaillard de sotteville pas français
j'achète pas revenons à nos bons
produits de chez nous je crois que à
evreux vous essayez d'être pilote en
quelque sorte pour les filières courtes
notamment pour la restauration
collective
absolument nous venons de lancer notre
appel d'offres pour les années qui
viennent dans le cas de notre unité
centrale de production et parmi les sept
lots attribués 4 notamment sont dédiés à
des filières courtes
encore faut-il que les agriculteurs
soient organisées et ça fait partie
aussi du rôle de la région avec la
chambre d'agriculture avec toutes les
organisations syndicales également que
de s'organiser
nous manquons aujourd'hui parfois deux
consortiums dans certaines filières pour
pouvoir assurer en permanence
l'approvisionnement de nos structures
dokoui nous avons lancé ce produit donc
quatre structures cas de filières vont
pouvoir bénéficier des circuits coup et
puis nous
lançons un drive agricole c'est-à-dire
que les gens vont pour aller sur
internet commander est ensuite allé
chercher dans une ferme proche des
gouffres eux leurs produits alors
peut-être que effectivement les
agriculteurs n'ont pas vocation à être
bouché mais si ça permet de supprimer de
temps en temps certains intermédiaires
qui participent à la chute des revenus
des agriculteurs
nous y sommes favorables et puis enfin
le volet normandie fait normande parce
que je crois que nous devons développer
ce médine normandie la normandie est la
région la plus connue au monde après
laquelle voilà en termes de ventes au
rythme actuel et je pense qu'à médine
normandie ça de la valeur sa de la
qualité et travailler aussi sur la
qualité
c'est quelque chose de fondamental or
justement monsieur lefranc qu'il faut
pas aller plus loin
quand vous allez en bretagne vous voyez
des drapeaux bretons un peu partout vous
avez le drapeau breton sur le beurre
voilà est ce que on ans m'ont dit
peut-être parce qu'on est des taiseux
comme on dit dans le pays de caux on
n'ose pas trop justement développé sa
propre image gaza vaches mangent aussi à
faire de ce côté leur quoi ça va changer
justement hervé morin s'est engagé à ce
que le drapeau normand deviennent
l'emblème de la normandie réunifiée
nous devons développer nous parlions de
la gourmandise qui est une très belle
image mais qui aujourd'hui c'est un peu
assouplie un peu endormi sur ses
lauriers
nous pouvons relancer ce notion de
gourmandise mais le met mais ce n'est
pas forcément facile à vendre à
l'étranger et le made in normandie c'est
simple c'est facile avec le drapeau
normand
ça passera par tous voilà et puis on
peut préciser quand même quand il eut
des fêtes normand de guénels tout le
monde s'en souvient autour de cette
table ça plus marcher en basse normandie
caen haute normandie il faut quand même
leur appeler ça du tout oui je voulais
ajouter dans la continuité de monsieur
lefranc gourmandie n'est pas en perte de
vitesse gourmandie j'étais encore ce
matin avec les responsables à champ de
l'agriculture de caen gourmandie
continue sa progression des vivres et
mobilisable le travail de mener on a
fait encore le bilan ce matin de la
période des jeux équestres mondiaux et
de ce qui a encore permis un envol pour
les produits normands je crois qu'on est
vraiment dans le vrai ce qui nous manque
sans doute pour demain c'est vraiment
l'identité normande alors gourmandie en
fait partie mais normandie et lyon
demain effectivement la marque normandie
sur tous les produits qui partent à
l'autre bout du monde
sur le plan de la consommation
dans notre région je crois
qu'effectivement on a beaucoup progressé
depuis quatre ans la région basse
normandie a mis en place le plan
régional d'alimentation de restauration
durable dans les vices et ses 5 millions
600 mille repas par an eh bien nous
avions prévu qu'au bout de quatre ans et
au moins 80 % de l'assiette de nos
lycéens où il y avait au moins deux
produits normands nous aujourd'hui nous
en sommes à trois produits normands et
donc tout est en marche dans beaucoup de
départements avec les collèges les
choses avancent beaucoup
donc il faut continuer dans ce sens là
mais ne faisons pas aujourd'hui
uniquement un sanctuaire
on a besoin aussi de pouvoir vendre et
exporter et je crois que quelqu'un l'a
dit tout à l'heure il doit être fort de
pour une question de logique de
consommer le plus proche locales comme
on dit penser le global et agir local
mais faisons en sorte aussi d'être
toujours dans la coopération parce qu on
a aussi besoin de vendre nos produits
identifiés en europe dans le monde parce
que sinon si nous nous enfermons comme
j'entends beaucoup de gens le dire
aujourd'hui en dix ans fermons toutes
les frontières
faisons en sorte de ne plus accueillir
personne parce que rabat son nous bien
mais quand on a fait appel au tourisme
eh bien on fait appel aux touristes et
au tourisme de toute la planète donc
essayons de jauger l'aspect humain de la
production et du marché
monsieur 21 dernières questions
d'internautes c'est philippe à caen qui
le monde qui dit il c'est difficile
voire impossible de trouver du lait cru
bon vous savez on en trouve ça se trouve
si on doit pouvoir trouver du lait cru
et tout le monde a à côté chez soi un
petit producteur si on doit pouvoir en
trouver les mots ni retrait sur quoi il
faut exposer un petit peu de mal mais on
doit pouvoir trouver du lait cru on peut
donner qu'une jour et revenir sur ce que
ce qu'a dit mon voisin je voudrais le
décliner à mon niveau c'est penser
régional agir nationale
je voudrais aussi
donner mon avis là sur les caricatures
que j'ai entendu il s'agit pas de
dresser des frontières de fermer les
frontières
il s'agit de de réguler il s'agit de
deux d'instaurer des droits de douane
intelligent il s'agit pas d'empêcher de
passer quoi que ce soit il faut protéger
nos producteurs il faut protéger par
exemple en normandie de la filière lin
qui est qui est tout à fait qui est une
des premières productions de notre
région
le lin textile est mis en valeur dans
notre région et mis dans des containers
ski partir des bateaux en chine pour
nous vendre des chemises de petite
qualité fabriqués par des esclaves en
asie est ce que c'est ça le est ce que
c'est ça l'avenir ce que c'est ça le
progrès je ne crois pas merci merci à
vous on va maintenant parce que chaque
semaine en fait la voix est libre tend
le micro aux habitants de la villa qui
nous reçoit pour savoir ce qu'ils
attendent de ces élections régionales
s'ils se sentent concernés on verra donc
au fil dès samedi si cela évolue
frédéric lafont et eric lambert ont donc
donné la parole aux habitants d'evreux
on les écoute bah on n'est pas si
différente ça au final non je me dis que
c'est pas plus mal le construisons les
gens vont se battre à qui aura la
priorité sur l'autre et particulièrement
entre l'aviron est celle de deux camps
et voir du havre je suis peu trop
informés sur soi chose je ne regarde pas
trop les avons en ce moment
j'espère j'espère moins de frais de
gestion
1 ce qui implique peut-être moins de
fonctionnaires et qui posera des
problèmes de 2
hommage je pense qu'on aura plus de
crédits + 2
2dans prises pour s'il ya des grands
projets à faire les grands ensembles
doivent coexister doivent également un
subsister pour faire plus de force
donner plus de vigueur à la vis d'eux
des citoyens dans les collectivités
donc on verra si ça évolue au fil du
temps mais qui boudent évidemment il ya
du travail à faire pour intéresser les
électeurs tout à fait alors il ya du
travail d'abord c'est pas les élections
qui marche le mieux celles qui marchent
le mieux c'est l'élection présidentielle
et les élections municipales south et
les régionales je crus teint
proportionnelle avec prime majoritaire
c'est pas obligatoirement et vireux puis
à 50% et un sondage ipsos france 3 qui
indique que ces élections sont vues par
50% des gens comme étant des élections
nationales et 50% comme des élections
régionales
autant dire que tout va se mélanger un
petit peu et c'est d'où l'intérêt je
pense j'espère tout en tout cas
d'essayer d'expliquer des choses y
compris sur france 3 merci philippe
heures fin de cette voie est libre
depuis la médiathèque d'evreux merci à
nos invités d'avoir été présents pour ce
premier débat consacré à l'agriculture
en normandie
nous vous donnons rendez vous samedi
prochain à 11h05 à la cité de la mer de
cherbourg pour parler énergies bien sûr
et économie de la mer très bon samedi à
vous